when the Hinshaw family moves into
summer wind the house speaks to them in
whispers in time
whispers become scream
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up here we are again whether I
like it or not we're back we've got a
good episode today we do have a very
good episode today today's episode is a
haunting of summer or is it be haunting
it's the haunting a compliment or
whatever close enough one of our
favorite episodes out of the haunting
series yeah first two seasons were the
best out of that one I think and this
was a cream of the crop yeah so we're
going to discuss this case today and
well what actually would the reason we
got this idea was because one of our
regular YouTube listeners John John our
yeah um said that we should do a show on
how he felt about like various
paranormal shows and you know with
paranormal witness and a haunting and
stuff like that and I said you know
that's kind of a cool idea and you know
what we should do is that we should pick
like because we really like a haunting
and I like five seasons of that and I
have five seasons of it on DVD like I
bought it for him for Christmas
birthdays over various years and so we
really like that show a lot and we
thought well and maybe maybe this might
be like a once a month kind of deal
where like we'll pick our one of our
favorite episodes you will review it and
we'll review it and then we'll talk
about the actual case behind the show
yeah like a case analysis yeah stuff
like that so thank you I think John it
was a good that was a good idea it might
actually make this a regular feature
yeah yeah and Johnson another army guy
like me and he served in Korea like I
did I think about a year or two apart
yeah so he's cool guys been with us
through the beginning
yeah he's listened to every single one
of our shows so thank you man yeah we're
gonna do it we're good we're do reviews
on regular basis so we might as well
start off with a haunting series cuz
everybody knows it yeah and we'll rip on
it if it isn't good or we'll say it's
good if it is good you know we'll we'll
uh we'll give you what we thank you know
we're not going hold back yeah sure so
be cool look agent housecleaning first
off yes
so um podcast yes podcast going through
the roof thanks to the project
Entertainment Network and the hard work
of our laverne's Amelia yes who has been
advertising her show and you know kind
of supporting our show us and all the
other podcasts that are on the project
Entertainment Network our
numbers tripled already quite everyone
quadrupled in two weeks yeah because it
went from about a thousand downloads to
about four thousand a thousand downloads
a month - what was it four thousand see
last month we had no this is just the
audio show this was at the YouTube Rio
but last month
audio downloads we had about 3,300 okay
download this month already
yeah and we and I've only put up what
like one or two shows this month yeah
this month we already have almost 6767
how do you think a lot of had to do with
the ed lorraine warren video that we
people really did seem to like that i
didn't realize how many brats have any
fans they right so we have tenant we
have new listeners on board and you know
probably a good time to give you guys
some background for coming in this late
although it seems to argue that it seems
like you're going through the old
episodes now yeah it does seem like a
lot of the old episodes are getting
downloaded too so people must be
discovering the show and then going back
and downloading all our old stuff Ginny
and I are not professional podcasters we
don't move on this I live in Italy right
we we basically do this for fun and we
do it for the scene jenny is a
paranormal nonfiction author and she's
got at least four you have to get for
paranormal nonfiction yeah yeah and then
anthem horror fashion terror fiction her
new one is the unseen hand she's been a
um which is about poltergeist it's like
over a hundred hundred some odd cases
yeah guys going all the way back to I
think the first century first century
lady is Josie is what is ah and she's a
regular guest on other paranormal shows
you just did what was that show you did
a couple weeks ago Jim Harold Harold
Harold I did end up days I heard the
road go I haven't done that yet I'm
doing I'm scheduled to go down in Jaipur
I've been on that one before and real
paranormal activity I was on that with
Erin hunter I was on knowledge and we
never really intended to make a big
podcast or a big show that's just kind
of snowballed as it went so mentally I'm
still doing this for like guys like John
are there's like four or five people up
and to me it's like I'm getting to show
it only for five people but everybody
like I'm always so
because what I mean me and you we just
kind of even when we're not being
recorded we just kind of sit around and
[ __ ] all the time that stuff and
make jokes and everything and like the
fact that so many people like wanted to
listen to us do that like I'm yeah on
tape as it were yeah that's very funny
to me well I know people like it I guess
people like it oh yeah we give a little
bit of the inside we don't want to
[ __ ] nothing else
yeah and picking a case is bad and we
talked about [ __ ] that we think is
interesting like we don't really I mean
we just got I know like our podcast
episodes if you look at the topics
they're kind of all over the place
and you don't really make any sense but
that's just because you know we just
like what are we going to do this week
is like ah maybe let's do but and then
we'll just think of something ever and
amore someone will remind us of
something we'll do show about it you
know what horror movies or true crime or
paranormal stone or whatever so we don't
really have any agenda we're just kind
of like whatever I feel is interesting
so welcome to the show guys mostly
talking to the podcast people I think we
have about 450 subs on YouTube and our
YouTube show it is visually really cool
and then it seems to be based on the
numbers right now on the podcast with
five about 4,000 regulars I think on
there yes about probably based on
animals prob about 4,000 of them give or
take
so welcome good luck into the show let's
start with the haunting of summerwine
and the first let's just talk about a
haunting the series of hande yeah well
you think of it now how many gosh how
many seasons does it down because I kind
of lost track of it after about season 6
or 7 yeah it's still on though right
they're still making my web still on by
the time the third and fourth season
started to come out I started to like
not watch it as much because I didn't
like how they how they portrayed things
I started to copy like horrible little
too much yeah fake scares we call it
yeah I'm scared well here's a bag eg now
here's number taken liberties with it oh
yeah big time yeah well here's the
here's something that bothered me and
they didn't do this as much because I
bought like you have I bought you the
bond debt three four and five of yeah so
we have the first five seasons and I see
some of the other ones like on on
destination America and why not now it
seems to me that after the first season
or two they really I mean the first
Caesars who I really like them because
even if I thought the story was [ __ ]
like they were still creepy yeah they
were fun to watch and they were fun to
watch the writer taming the set was good
the set I like that things are
restrained you're restrained right yeah
they didn't go over the top there wasn't
kind of attended to stick with the
witness testimony yeah everything would
embellish you embellish if the witness
said they saw something that's what
they'd show ya later on they were
showing stuff that the witnesses never
mentioned which I did really like yeah
because the witness always often in
about felt like someone was watching me
and then in the reenactment there's like
a demon like yeah I'm like they didn't
say that they saw that right so just
quit doing that yeah it's a little
deceptive it was a little bit but the
one that really from day one that really
stood out there was a lot there's
actually four or five minutes stand up
yeah man we get demon without we're
definitely gonna have to do what on that
because it's like no man said it was
okay yeah man said it would be fun are
you peeing in the closet man said I got
it it was awesome we still use that man
said I hit ya man said it man the demons
name was Manny
yeah L know it wasn't one about mr.
Gordy that was was first season one
episode when Isaiah and hungry ghosts
ones worthy were they were in Taiwan
they are in Taiwan and it's implied that
the the ghosts were raping the girls
yeah they didn't really come out and say
that I cried say I think I've got that
impression right so I want to talk about
all these yeah we might have to do that
one I think the king of them all was the
one that really kind of got me the one
that got me interested in that series
was a hobby a summer one yeah and that
was season 1 episode 2 rod and we
seriously every time we pull those DVDs
out he always wants to rewatch that one
we've probably seen it like 20 times
well I'm fascinated with records
Hey where's our rec room ha ha I'm with
a raccoon table where Jacqueline and
that actors used over and over jungles
yeah he was in a bunch of the other one
every time I see him I'm asking hey man
where's record anyway I'm totally using
that sound buy it like from now on every
time that's going to be a running get
that record where's my record because I
did I didn't try not bound by hey that's
ok just lick it let's get that let's get
to how the story is how it was portrayed
in the episode and then show us the
differences it show us what you dug up
about this case okay well on the show uh
it took place in Wisconsin in 1969 and
evidently there's this woman named
ginger Henshaw and she was married to a
guy named Arnold hmm um on the show they
have four kids okay they actually had
six but whatever all right so they do
want to hire two more kids I guess very
good enough yeah that's fine just a
bunch of kids a gaggle so evidently they
were driving around and they saw this
kind of dumpy looking house although it
looked okay in the episode yeah in the
episode look like a nice house with some
planks and debris thrown out in front of
it yeah you look at end of line six and
twenty minutes yeah we're the dumpster
yeah just gotta clean it yeah but that's
not the way that house really looked
yeah we're going to show we're showing
pictures of it probably right now yeah
the UM YouTube show yeah but so okay so
evidently so ginger Henshaw who was
interviewed on the show you know much
older obviously and um she said she fell
in love with the house and she figured
oh we can fix it up and all this other
kind of stuff so they buy the house now
I don't not like it didn't seem like it
took that long before the paranormal
[ __ ] started happening now the first
thing she said started to happen was she
started to get this um compulsion to put
the house back the way it was yeah she
felt like she was possessed by this
to totally restore the house and even
like get the exact matching paint color
and all the other way I was yeah now
they claim that they tried to contact
like various contractors and repair guys
and stuff like that and that no one
would work on the house when they
discovered where it was like which house
it was right now it should be noted that
the house I mean they call it summer
wind and that's usually how its
portrayed although locally in Wisconsin
the house has actually noticed the
Lamont mansion because that was the name
of the main family that lived there back
in the day yeah but uh you know summer
wind that's what they call it I guess
some people call Alaska now what I
remember I first when I was first heard
of this case I was watching the episodes
for the first time I thought boy that's
strange they don't want to come and work
on the house but then I go back and now
that I have access you know and I could
see what house it is what I was like
actually in cellars to make a little bit
hit the Morissette house was in pretty
bad shape
yeah the best way to get that house
looking good would be to tear that house
down start all over again
ha ha ha like I said it was how did it
look to the way it looked in the episode
huh then yeah it didn't seem like it was
that big a deal right but when you saw
it with your photographs of it yeah
you'll know why probably nobody wanted
to granted the photographs that I was
look that we're looking at probably come
from about 87 maybe yeah now 84 yeah and
this was happening the story is being
told from one of you about 1969
yeah I think that's what they thought
was ginger and shot her husband bone the
house and the garden houses go that's
not a big that may have a lot of time
right I was living in Boston I'm the
analysis that was built in mid 1800s
yeah and I'm we're still out there yeah
right which that's a story that was a
weird house I'm gonna talk about that
right now but our state was hot it was
just it was a creepy old house yeah yeah
but look a lot better than this one that
they were talking about Lamont mansion
not only was it
dilapidated struck architectural II it
sucked it was it was
ugly you could yeah though the guy tells
the story uh which once guy is that he
said that it looked like it that it
didn't really have any yeah so now that
yeah that was great
Raymond Beaubourg Reina that we were
ginger Henshaw father I he's saying it
was hard to kind of place the
architectural style
yeah I'd place it place the
architectural style bad yes that's
that's what I thought it bad
the house was built from as far as I
could determine in 1916 or 1917 yeah
okay so you have to think by 1969 it was
pretty old and it had been abandoned for
a while I wasn't able to do I think on
the show they said it had been abandoned
for forty years
yeah I don't know about that but some of
the newspaper articles I found said has
been abandoned for some time for some
time so and when it wasn't in great
shape when they came across and look
like a cross between a colonial home a
Bavarian barn and something out of the
Old West to me that's what it looked
like yeah it looked pretty bad look
tacky yeah okay so now on the show is
weird because the story that the family
tells to the newspaper and that was in
like a like various books and stuff like
that was actually um worse than what
they showed on the show right on the
show the family moved in she gets this
compulsion to start fixing it up now her
husband Arnold
starts acting strangely like he loses
interest in working on the house like I
said they couldn't get anyone else to
help them work on it like workmen would
come and just bring stuff up to the
driveway then said nope I'm not coming
any closer see is you know I mean so
they had to do a lot of the work
themselves
Arnold loses interest in the house right
stops going to work stops going to work
at some point and it starts acting very
strangely like he's just staring out of
windows and then he starts getting real
aggressive violent and violent yelling
at his children like just getting all
upset at the slightest provocation he
also thought that people were
opening and closing or opening the
windows yeah Grayson who opened that
window
yeah oh the windows would open and close
were on their own right and he'd set
down tools and turn around they'd be
gone be gone so he would blame the kids
for taking the tools the kids lost the
raccoon
yeah directly went outside when the rat
couldn't came back he killed it as
punishment yeah which is uh one of the
daughters said that and the actor that
played the role of this guy in the
episode is awesome yeah it's a really
creepy episode especially the first half
of the episode he sits there and he
plays on the Oregon creepy music and
many amber all that I don't care I'll
play all night if I have to yeah none of
that
that was another how they go to sleep I
don't care possessed by the house yeah
now apparently I think in the Hammond
organ that he played in the episode they
had had that for a while they brought it
to the house I don't think they
mentioned that on the episode but um
yeah ginger said that he would start
playing this organ just like day and
night and that was all he wanted to do
it's almost like the demons in his head
were telling that he had to keep playing
it and in the episode it was kind of
creepy it was like it was kind of like
carnival souls and their guys have seen
that where she was like an organ player
and like her the organ plane was getting
all creepy and yeah you know all
distorted yeah he would be they
portrayed it pretty cool yes definitely
going and kriti was definitely going
insane and you kind of go insane
watching this part of the episode like
whoa yeah maybe that made an impression
on me yeah yeah but anyway you guys you
don't even know how many how often would
say that so it seems like so he starts
flipping out I think ginger was also a
kind of hearing voices and she saw a
couple of apparitions not like full body
kind of apparitions I think she saw like
kind of ghostly looking yeah in your
hand she had some guests over when she
was in the kitchen she heard a scream
and ran out to the guest room where they
were and she saw them getting up and run
yeah now the house and in the corner she
saw and like there's like a face they're
saying like that yeah missed with
face in it and evidently those friends
would never spoke to her again yeah
Jenna saw again so I think yeah also I
think before that it ran through or she
was in a hallway remember and it was
yeah I got something behind her and it
ran right through her yeah I'll face
anyway it was pretty creepy and I think
the kids like that now like I said I
think in real life they were six kids
but I think only one of the daughters
was on the actual show I'm getting
interviewed yeah and they're compelling
the witnesses are very compelling yeah I
really believed what they what they're
saying especially the first batch yeah
because actually this whole haunting of
summerwine episode is two stories told
back-to-back the first story and the
second story yeah they're the same
family but the first one is the daughter
her husband and the kids and then later
the daughter's father yeah her brother
and his family once they moved into it
cuz they left she left anyway you get to
that yeah so yeah one of the daughters
was on there and she was talking about
you know how her dad yeah on the show I
think was her stepdad but I don't
everything I read about the real case I
thought that was her real dad yeah they
like seemed like it was yeah that's how
it was portrayed at a time I believe
yeah like on the show I think they
implied that it was her stepdad but it
wasn't it was her real dad so he wigged
out and she was talking about the
daughter was talking about I don't think
the daughter like ever I don't remember
her ever saying on the show that she had
seen anything but she just said that he
was behaving strange like he was
possessed that the house seemed evil
that there was like it was an aggressive
is that evil was in him that he became
evil he killed the raccoon and was
abusive towards him yeah yeah yeah so
what ended up happening then was after
all this stuff happened ginger took the
kids and called her dad and said come
get me I can't take this anymore because
you know it was 1969 she wasn't working
she was sick I mean she was taking care
of the kids yeah but she left out and
that's how it's not cool part of what
happened it got so bad because they were
that that because he wouldn't go to work
that's what I was just going to say how
power went out they ended up in the
living room burning the furniture in the
fireplace and it was so fun yeah and she
couldn't stand it in the house earlier
she was actually sleeping outside and
she had a knife on her at all times that
she thought her her insane boy her
husband was gonna kill her they were
married yeah yeah yeah but he did he was
getting by she thought he thought that
he was dangerous yeah so but yeah that
felt that was that kind of stuck with me
that they were actually burning the
furniture yeah because he wouldn't get
to work anymore
no refused a good worker yeah so all
their bills got unpaid and when he left
with the kids she left with the kids
they left him in that place by himself
yeah according to the episode although
the episode said that he left the next
day rough now that's not quite what
happened Blanca data venema okay so on
the show so she takes off she takes the
kids she calls her dad says come get me
I can't take this anymore
her dad comes in the camper and picks
her up she moves away the husband
Arnold they get a divorce and he they'd
never hear from him again evidently a
little while later it wasn't clear how
how long a span this was from the show
but a little while later she had told
her father about this house and she told
him everything to happen there aunt in
it oh without the haunting and
everything he didn't believe it and he
did not believe her no and he was very
skeptical and stuff like that now he
went to look at the house and meanwhile
someone else had bought it or is
reverted to someone else now no one was
living in it right that's not mentioned
in it in the episode but that's
evidently what really happened somebody
else bought it right yeah that old that
older woman had bought it right and um
yes okay yes she wasn't living in it
right but she had just bought it for I
don't know why but um Jim Gardner and
she wouldn't go in there yeah she just
bought it for the hell of it I guess but
she wouldn't go in there so the father
goes to look at the house and for some
reason feels compelled he's like I'm
gonna buy this house and I'm gonna fix
it up and I'm gonna turn it into like a
bed-and-breakfast or certain like that
and his son just come back from Vietnam
yeah and he was going to work on it also
yeah they were both going to work out
because they were both in the
action been a story was that they
thought they could do something with it
it thought they would buy it fix it up
cause we flip I guess that's what they
you know and then you say don't flip it
but yeah that's what I figured that
they're been doing this was gonna be a
project yeah project house yeah so you
know evidently it had been a little
while since she left because when they
went in there to work on it they said it
was more degraded and she I mean she had
done some work on it I think they lived
there for six months yes so okay so what
ended up happening was one day the son
was there working on the house by
himself right and he evidently saw
something so scary then he took off out
of the house I didn't tell anybody would
and he wouldn't tell anybody what it was
until later and in the episode they
don't show you what it was not until
later not till later yeah now you only
find out what it was
later on when okay so the father tells
ginger hey I bought that house and she
was like why the [ __ ] did you do that
you know don't you remember everything I
told you in blah blah blah and he's like
I will be fine it's not going on and
you're just crazy or whatever you know
cuz [ __ ] be crazy
alright so okay so then she notices that
the son or her brother rather I think
isn't Carl and he was like freaking out
and he was really scared and everything
now since she had left the house she had
been super interest in the paranormal
and she was studying hypnosis everything
cuz you know 70s and everybody was into
that so she says she's going to
hypnotize him right
so she hypnotizes them and he starts
talking in a different voice yeah like
sounding like and he's like all my
children are so weak and I am strong
yeah like so I guess the implication
being that the evil spirit that was in
the high block right no but they really
don't get anything out of that yeah now
they said in the in the quarter they
reported it right but you know I haven't
heard the recording Rory off recording
so so the dad said well hypnotize me and
they got into automatic writing yes when
this Carver sub J right yeah comes in to
enter the show yeah and
Carver was some kind of Explorer yes and
he was a real guy real God he went quite
a bunch of land and they think there was
some kind of a land dat with the Native
Americans that were there at the time it
starts to get a little bit convoluted
they did find evidently the original
blueprints to the house wrapped up
around peace pipe yeah so they went on a
quest to try to find the land deed yes
now the father Raymond Bober he said
that he had had a dream in which he was
in the house or it was it was either
when he was under hypnosis or he had a
dream or something like that but he said
he had a dream where he was in the house
and he went down to this cellar and
there was like a little rock like part
of the baseboard and he pried it off and
there was a space behind it like a
secret hiding space and there was a
little black box in there with a land
deed in it and he said the name Jonathan
Carver was on right they think they
think that it's being haunted by
Jonathan Carver and that he's missing
his land deed that they somehow can get
the land deed settled at the haunting
will and that's what they're thinking
right so he has this vision in a trance
then they end up going to the house and
trying to find the deed right where they
saw it but it wasn't there they turn
turn the house upside down they could
not find this deed now they claimed that
there was a space behind this particular
but it was empty like a secret hided
hole but yeah but there was nothing in
it what ended up happening after that
okay so then the the brother Karl he
tells them okay well what I saw in the
house I was in the house and he heard
someone or no he heard gunshots yeah
really close by yeah well okay this is
this is how that went down like at once
once he was listen to that tape yeah and
all this little automatic writing and
all this little psychic experimentation
that they were doing he goes back and
tells him why he ran out of the house a
few weeks or two months prior yeah he he
said that he heard gunshots
two of them up close and then when he
looked into a room there was nobody
there
yeah and that they couldn't have escaped
you know that he was on the second floor
ran out of there he felt like something
why
you know that that's how I remember that
yeah and then later on in the house they
find two bullet holes I've identified
well okay when Everton the woman who
owned the house heard a story that the
original owners at one time saw a ghost
and fired off two round that and then
yeah now on the TV show yeah it says
that the people that lived in it in the
1930s rug and on the show they called
them two Patterson's but it was actually
the Lamont family in real life I don't
know why they changed the name they're
always doing that you'll find out yeah I
always do that in each series yeah but
they changed the name it was actually
the Lamont family that this legend grew
up about although I don't know if it's
turn around right evidently Lamont and
his wife were sitting in their kitchen
one night in 1935 or there abouts and
the the door from the kitchen into the
basement opened by itself right and they
saw an apparition
yeah Lamont grabbed a pistol and fired
two shots yet the ghost because I guess
he thought he was going to kill the
ghost with a gun I don't know how and in
the episode was kind of a cool scene it
was a cool effect it's kind of like a
man-sized cloud with a human face in it
and then the the God what was his name
what was his reeling in Patterson that's
what they called him in the shadow to
the column in the show his real name is
my little moth yeah he reaches into a
drawer pulls out a colt 1911 it fires
off two rounds into it yeah pretty cool
and they claim like they went when they
went back to the house to look for the
deed they claimed that there are still
two bullet holes in the door now there
are photographs yeah that were taken in
the 80s yeah by people who went to the
house later after it was abandoned and
evidently there are pictures of the door
that does have two holes in it whether
they're bullet holes or not I don't know
max I'm listening to experts yeah but
like I said I'm not sure if that's her
issue that's what the lady that owned
the house said she said there was a
legend about Lamont that he shot at a
ghost in there were tubes okay so that's
what they were hearing was these two
gunshot all right we're almost at the
halfway point how does this series end
how does it wrap up and then we'll go
back to our now pretty much it wraps up
with I think after they went and looked
for the deed and they couldn't find it
in the tour of the house of them
like that it like is the episode ended
with them going be like well we've
wasted too much time on this bucket
basically and now in kind of the end in
the house get struck by lightning and
either because of evil forces and it
burns down yeah which did I mean evil
forces that around but it the healthy
that it burned down in 1981 but indicee
in the episode they threw sound effects
and movie magic was destroyed by evil 4
yeah I think in the show they said it
was struck by lightning multiple bonds
and I don't think that's the case I
think it was only sharp ones that caught
fire I mean the house was made of wood
mostly yeah
so we'd burned to the ground in 1988 so
it's not there anymore there's still a
Bruin like I think the chimneys are
still there but the house itself is not
there burned down in 1988 if you haven't
seen the episode go watch it right now
and then the second half you'll see our
analysis yeah well we'll talk about the
episode we'll talk about what really
happened will me about all this other
stuff so we're going to take a break
right now and we will be back in just a
minute our cast dead sexy podcasts I'm
your host Armand Rose Amelia Fridays
exclusively on project Entertainment
Network where I interview authors
publishers editors artists filmmakers
narrators the lady from Walmart whoever
I feel like talking to that's every
Friday arm cast right here on project
entertainment network subculture corsets
in clothing is our favorite store for
unusual clothing shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets comm set subculture
corsets comm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount
subculture corsets comm or visit their
store in Jacksonville Florida just off
i-95
every person story has something to
teach us however is view life how
obstacles are overcome how joy is felt
how fears are faced how love is
expressed the matters of faith podcast
explores individual stories of people's
lives and how faith plays a part it may
not be your story but it may help shape
yours the matters of faith podcast with
Jay Warren is on project entertainment
network
[Music]
[Music]
you
all right haunting of summer wind yeah
it's a good one it is a very good
episode love that oh so it is good now
the nice thing about blend like I said I
mentioned this before but the nice thing
about the early haunting episodes they
were very restrained yeah you know they
didn't show there was like yeah there
was ghosts on this and stuff but it was
there was no demons there was no nothing
like that
well there was some demons I guess right
but it wasn't like they were on the top
they were having guys in Halloween masks
like popping out of people's closets and
[ __ ] like that know they kind of drew me
in numbers I think it I don't know if it
was the music or what just the way they
re and that and that guy's voice is very
calm yeah
yeah like sometimes we'll just kind of
put them on one after the other and just
get a lay there I wanna say yeah because
I got Americana's true evil guys voices
it's Susan I don't know who that guy is
he does like a lot of poise a rhythm for
that kind of stuff but he has a great
voice yeah but so okay what okay so that
was now that was the emotional inversion
right what were you able to dig up about
this case okay
now because it is not all as it seems is
it no okay well it never is never these
I mean the show's they're trying to make
a good show and like you know I have to
say haunting of Summerland you know the
show is pretty accurate mostly to what
these people claim happened but it
should be noted that most of the
information and most of the story that
came out about this house later came
from a book that ginger Henshaw's father
Raymond Bober wrote about a house it was
called the Carver effect I believe yeah
and so that was where most of this
information came from right so it's
pretty much I mean ginger was on the was
on the program
her dad was on the program her brother
was on the program and one of her
daughters was on the program so they you
know these were the witnesses that were
on the show and they had a similar kind
of story that this is what happened okay
the thing about summer wind
like I said in Wisconsin is generally
called the Lamont mentioned because that
was the name
the other prominent families that lived
there the house was built in the early
you know like 1916 1917 it was built as
a summer house or I think it was
originally built as a fishing lodge but
then it was expanded to like a summer
house by the Lamont family who were kind
of prominent like up in the government
he was in like I don't even remember now
but he was in someone's he was
somebody's Secretary of State or
Secretary of Commerce or something like
that tell us what was left out okay now
the funny thing is that some of the
stuff that was left out yeah was
actually kind of pretty good
interestings I don't know why they left
it out okay now you know how Arnold like
would possess quote/unquote and like
slipped out and stuff like that yeah now
in the episode they just kind of showed
ginger and the kids leaving and him
staying in the house and then it just
said oh he left the next day and that's
all they said now evidently in real life
he had a full-on nervous breakdown and
they they said he went for treatment so
I guess they put him in a psychiatric
hospital for a while right but they got
divorced later now ginger attempted
suicide or so it claims and all these
other things they did not mention that
on the show and she did not mention it
she was on the show talking another
thing that they didn't they actually
they left out some of the haunting stuff
they left out that they claimed that a
lot of their appliances and stuff like
that when they moved them in a house
it's like they would get new appliances
and then they would work and then they
wouldn't work right and then they would
call a repair guy and then they would
start working again okay so like they
were having all kinds of like electrical
difficult but Elmo was the big one
though the big thing that was left it
okay now the big thing and I don't know
why they left this out because this is I
kind of suspect why they that's it well
you have oh yeah go ahead back to but
this is great I don't know why they
didn't put it in so okay so while
they're renovating the house ginger and
Arnold this is before Arnold started
flipping out so they are in this closet
right and they start painting it in
there now against the back wall of the
closet there's like a big drawer like a
shoe drawer and they pull it out because
they don't want the paint to get on it
and get stuck closed and everything like
that now when they pull it out they
notice that there's this big dark gap
behind there so Arnold gets a flashlight
and he sticks his head in there and six
the flashlight and he says that he sees
skeleton okay now he says he's not
entirely sure because there's so much
plumbing and all this other kind of
stuff back there so when the kids come
home from school I guess they're small
enough to kind of get in there and see
better so they give so they give the
kids a flashlight and they crawl in
there and look it's not clear because
the kid says the daughter Mary said that
she saw black hair and part of a brown
arm and so like I'm like where they
bones or wait I got a cure
and is this a human body yeah all right
now what is the source where's this
story up here well this story this is
from this actually what I'm reading from
this is from the Milwaukee Journal night
it from 1985 okay but this story was
came from a book called haunted
heartland by Beth Scott and Michael
Norman and I'm assuming that this came
from the family's testimony testimony
we're not Providence and but this is a
man dog live from Raymond bober's book
okay
the Carver effect this was ginger
Henshaw dad who supposedly bought that
right now we're not positive if the
corpse story came from his book are we
um I'm not I think most of this did
because I think that was the main story
we don't have that book so we can't
check we're just but the main source for
all the haunting stuff generally is
comes from his book which I focus
written in 1980 or Never but here's the
strange thing you're claiming that they
saw by inside the walls of this but they
found a corpse final but they didn't go
to the cops yeah they said they didn't
go to the cops because it would have
been too old yeah it's like Oh
everyone's dead that's involved with it
so why bother yeah I'm not buying it I'm
like oh there's no statute of limitation
a murder no reward
that you didn't want to catch it and
another thing another thing is what kind
of people could sleep in a house knowing
that there's a dead body stashed into in
between the walls I ain't buying it yeah
yeah that's why I think that does not
appear in the episode maybe not maybe
they thought that that is a little jetty
yeah because then when they went back
later to try to prove
the veracity of this body it's not there
yeah that was it yeah yeah when did that
happen now that was another thing okay
now we're the thing about ginger and
them leaving like I said she attempted
suicide he was sent to like a
psychiatric hospital evidently they got
divorced now the dad either bought or
attempted to buy Summerwind
later on but there was a pretty big gap
because ginger had already remarried by
the time that her dad was to buy the
property I don't know and and that's
another thing is there is it it isn't
real certain whether he actually bought
the property or whether he was trying to
buy the pond yeah that's that's not
that's another issue some people say
that he never bought that property yeah
some people say that the records show
that he only attempted to buy it or the
Navy or never on the deed no I'm just
saying that's what it says the galang
yeah people say that he actually
actually never bought you can't verify
this we don't have the original books in
vault and of course to really know for
sure you have to go to town hall down
there yeah start pulling records out
because uh third parties jump on stories
like these and tend to add to them
yeah we're not actually we're not
totally positive that the corpse angle
on this story actually came from the
family that may have come come from
third parties that might be an
aftermarket upgrade we don't know yeah
and that's another thing is that after
her dad supposedly bought the house like
her her dad her new husband and her
brother were at the house and she told
them about the body because before when
they had found the body like a long time
ago when she was still married to the
crazy guy she said oh we're not going to
tell anybody about this all right but
later on like I guess it was probably at
least a year later I would imagine later
on like when her dad bought the house
she told about the body so they went to
look for it in the same place and it
wasn't there right which makes me very
suspect on barristers who would have
told who would have taken that I don't
know or unless you were saying oh it was
a ghostly body I we're not really there
for whatever all right what else that's
that's another and
I said there's no really proof what the
dad wanted to do was that he wanted to
turn in a restaurant he was trying to
get a permit at CERN in a restaurant he
couldn't get one and then he tried to
get a permit to open a concession stand
outside outside of the place he was a
popcorn vendor and right and he couldn't
get that either makes me believe that
that they probably bought the place and
trying to turn it into a tourist
attraction right and I think that that's
why I become a hold on one thing when
you look at the condition of this place
of what it would look like in those days
it would look like a haunted house yeah
by this time he already has his book out
Carver effect to me it appears that what
he's trying to do is to make kind of
like a tourist attraction slash
amusement park come look at the haunted
house to show concessions you know they
tell you popcorn when you go through
your tour they take the money and they
use that to renovate the house and it's
suspicious
yeah because that's yeah that's another
thing is like I said in the episode the
house didn't really look that bad it
looked a little bit degraded but not
really it still looks really good in
real life it looked like a ruin yeah go
onto YouTube go on our YouTube show if
you're on the podcast or even do a
search for Lamont mansion or some Realty
I'm Google car yeah it's a wooden house
it just looked like [ __ ] I mean it
looked like it look like crap yeah it
looked like you wouldn't be able to live
in there like two parts of the roof Oh
God yeah you know yeah it looks like a
total dump you look at the interior
photos and there's just so much work to
be done and actually the wood that was
used looks like it's untreated wood
everything looks very boat yeah the
whole house is sagging in the middle uh
so yeah that's that house you basically
have to tear it down rebuild it with
better wood I am reading wood yeah we
think you would just have to spend the
volume of make a really substandard
materials yeah I mean the foundation I
think is still there and of a stone that
was like the nicest part of it but yeah
the actual house himself looked like it
was entirely made of wood and it looked
like it had just been eaten and wet in
the other dry rot
yeah and it just looked like it was
falling apart yeah and okay so Raymond
Bober like I said also claimed that he
saw in a dream I saw it in a dream that
there was this
indeed and everything like that now
Jonathan Carver who apparently had
signed this land deed that he saw in the
dream that was hidden in his house and
stuff like that now that was a real guy
he was an explorer but legitimate
historians say that they don't think
that Carver ever explored that side of
the Mississippi River so we wouldn't
have been over there and he has no
connection to that house and he would
have no connection to that house there
like look by the time that house was
built Jonathan Carver had been dead like
a hundred and thirty-seven years right
right so how would that have gotten
there right and even if it had been
legitimate yeah it's just they tacked
his name onto it because anything here
oh yeah and even if there was a deed
they said it wouldn't have been legally
binding anyway just because of some
obscure laws with the Native American
zone yeah is that on yes so it's like
that so it wouldn't have made any
difference even if they had found it
like it wouldn't have made any
difference to who owned it or anything
like that now there is also a lot of
controversy about the original story
like I said in the show they said
Patterson the Patterson family and he
had shot at a ghost of Lottie blah I
think most sources I found said that
that story about the guy shooting at the
ghost didn't gain any ground until that
dudes book until Grover's looking up
right now they have talked to various
locals that that have lived in the area
like old people that have lived in the
area for a really long time this is in
Wisconsin like I said around the Land
O'Lakes Wisconsin people that have lived
in the area they talked to a guy who
poured the foundation of the house and
lived there for a few months like while
he was working on it and things like
that and most locals 99% of the locals
they have interviewed said that house
was never considered haunted until after
it got abandoned and scary-looking
they said not at the time when people
were living in it no there was no legend
about it there was no no one shot it a
ghost
there was no saying
better being haunted and stuff like that
because I think the legend was that the
servant said it was haunted
the Lamont servants or the Patterson
servants or whoever said it was haunted
and the family didn't believe them and
then one night they saw the ghost and
shot at it or whatever and that's the
legend that went around about it but
that legend isn't old right but most
people said that they don't remember
anything about that
Brook because a lot of people that lived
around there like a couple like one
older lady that they interviewed in the
80s she said well I used to live next
door you know like not next door because
it's big but you know in the next house
down
she said well people thought it was
spooky looking just because it was big
but she's like I don't remember anyone
saying it was haunted there was ghosts
in there nothing like that she said
nobody said anything about it being
haunted until no one lived in it for a
long time and it started falling apart
yeah okay so final verdict is it real no
not as given not as given but I look at
the case I look at the case and to me
it's two separate stories the first part
of the story which is a young family
moves into a creepy house the husband
goes insane breaks up the family the
right-arrow normal Colonel effects were
reported then there's a pause then that
woman's father buys the place and goes
in there and has a memory seance that
has some psychic does some psychic
rituals with the automatic writing
self-hypnosis and comes up with this
Jonathan Carver character in a land deed
story comes up with a ghost story basic
yeah to me I think there's a possibility
that what you're seeing was a
poltergeist case happening and then the
the family moving away from the scene of
the poltergeist case and then the second
part is her father coming in trying to
capitalize on the poltergeist then by
making a hot house not doing what
poltergeist is hears you have a young
family with the young teenage girls
under a lot of stress the relationship
between the
stepdad an imam not too good it's a
creepy house that could be the rest
breath the recipe for a poltergeist
outbreak some along the lines of the
mouth mount like I tell you it could be
well because most of the first things
that they recorded were poltergeist type
things yeah I mean they were just
hearing funny noises like their
electrical things were messing up big
apparitions yeah stuff like that so it
didn't seem like I mean there didn't
really seem to be any kind of
quote-unquote ghosts trying to
communicate anything on a LAN or
anything like that now there is the
whole thing about a dad gets involved in
all of a sudden it's a full-on ghost can
all of a sudden a ghost story right yeah
I think half of the case there's a
possibility that the first half of the
case is true yeah maybe that maybe this
family moved in and like some kind of
weird should happen like you know and
maybe people were creeped out by house
or the house was so junky that most
contractors in the area didn't want to
work on it and maybe that's how the
family perceived oh they must be rare to
come in here right and stuff so they
kind of built it up in their minds maybe
and then you know it could have been a
case where there was just strange things
happening in the house and they
attributed it to that or who knows and
honestly I don't know what happened with
Arnold the father raccoon guy who just I
don't know if he just like flipped out
and he would have flipped out where no
matter where I'm there's no evidence I
mean because they didn't interviewed
that guy I don't know whatever happened
to go I hear his his son yeah all we're
hearing is her side of the story on how
he acted and her kids you know right
talking about it I don't doubt it but he
that guy might might not mention
anything about ghost or poltergeist yeah
he might have just gone berserk just
rust you know what I mean from it it
happens right you know he might have
been under a lot of stress and he just
kind of flipped out and had a nervous
breakdown and she kind of interpreted it
as the house doing it I have a feeling
that something weird happened in the
first yeah it might have been an item
and I kind of think something did happen
I don't believe the second half the
story
yeah when the dad gets involved in all
of a sudden you Native Americans and
land deeds and ottoman guys shooting it
go yeah automatic writing and hypnosis
that's very
1970s yeah typical typical 1970s
paranormal / ghost story for the time
probably didn't happen ya know next
second I think the second half of it was
try to capitalize on the first half on
the first half right well in a way it
kind of works because I work one there
was an episode of haunting and whew now
summer wind is known as the most haunted
house in Wisconsin even though the house
isn't there anymore John yeah it's gone
but like like I said that the chimneys
are still there how do I rate the
episode five stars this is seriously
it's his favorite up my favorite up so
it's his favorite episode and we watched
it about we watched it a couple times
yes right up to this even though we've
already there are several others to come
close but this event was my favorite
well I think yeah and like I said this
might be part of I were kind of thinking
about doing like kind of a semi-regular
yeah bit once a month or so just when we
had like where we'll pick one of our
favorite episodes because like I said we
definitely have to do the one which
we've got to pick a [ __ ] one though
- well yeah we gotta do some dumb ones
yeah yes and what do we don't play we
should do some paranormal witness ones
too because they were CLE dumb ones on
there now people the first the first
season a paranormal witness was very
good though well yeah it seems to happen
this is what happens with these shows
and the same thing happened with the
haunting the same thing happened with
paranormal witness when paranormal
witness first started I actually liked
the first season or two better than a
haunting I was like wow this is even
better just like creepier like it it was
more restrained because I tended I love
horror movies you know I'm a big horror
fan which everybody knows this listen to
this show regularly but I'm more a fan
of like restrained horror to read things
like that adult like jump scares I don't
really like you know just trying to be
scary for the sake of being scary I like
something that's like really you know
kind of low-key
but still creepy and it seemed like the
first couple seasons of haunting and the
first couple seasons of paranormal
witness were like that but then it seems
like they kind of went off the rails
because they were trying to make it seem
more like a horror movie right so like
we have to put demons in every episode
it and actually the the newer seasons of
a haunting the ones we've seen like I
said I'm not real sure what seasons are
on maybe eight or nine I don't know but
the new every time I see a new one on
destiny
America destination America it always
seems like they have an agenda yeah
like the old ones didn't really have and
uh some guys they call on a priest
sometimes not they don't really have any
kind of oh it's always a demon but it
seems like it's just like our last
week's show on the Warrens like it's
always a demon now although they got
they got purchased by a company called a
new Dominion although you know what I
was noticing is that a lot of the old
ones were new to the original then it
must be so maybe a present ours or
something yeah because it does their
marketing to a different different
demographic baby well we could see where
the competition is tougher so they're
just getting more and more outlandish
yeah cuz like on G is cheap now so yeah
that's probably awesome with the older
shows it seems like some of the ghost
stories they did like some of the ghosts
were like friendly or they were just
trying to impart information like oh
there's these letters and I killed
myself and I want you know I don't want
everybody to know about it or whatever
but now it seems like everything has to
be a dark force you know what I mean
everything has to be well evil you know
because I guess that's scarier whatever
that's what sells but you know it but I
almost like I don't know I kind of like
it I'm not saying that goes always have
to be friendly because yeah scarier when
they're made and stuff like that but I
think the ones where they're friendly or
kind of scary you know yeah right yeah
okay it's about time now I think it's
about time to wrap up oh gosh we're
right of your time we just laugh and
laugh okay well we're gonna wrap up the
show for this week and I hope you
enjoyed our rather rambling discussion
of the haunting and the haunting of
summer wind and that next week yeah
we'll shout out again to project
Entertainment Network you guys are doing
a phenomenal job arm on Rosa Millia
especially especially with our download
numbers and stuff like that also if
you're into the paranormal
obviously I wrote a book called the
unseen hand and it's still available and
will be available forever so go get
eBook print and audio book and if you
like it then leave a review because it
really does help and that'll do it for
this episode right Yeah right we're done
all right see you next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
the law
I love to be
my family
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]